back-to-back youtube with my girl how
are you i'm great first of all matt gala
now tonight with savage experience so
cute in this thank you darling i mean i
got a dress for my girlfriend it's a
little like a look more casual than i
used to seeing you i i like you in this
cash i was like i'm dressing up tonight
y'all yeah yeah no you are dressed up
you always in a gown
the diamond ball always showing me up we
go oh police i could not show you what
but honey you are showing yourself up
with this volume three always take into
your show your shows to the next level
what was your visit what was your vision
for this show rihanna oh well
i knew what the collection was and i
knew i wanted a space that or whatever
build out we made to be something
special and something that married the
collection well
but i got a bunch of venues a lot of
warehouses when i saw this hotel it was
like mind-blowing i knew it had to be
the space it was perfect
so many ideas
that you could do and accomplish within
a space like that and we took advantage
of all of those you sure did but you
know
you take it to next levels and fans are
going to be excited to see so much but
they're particularly going to be excited
to see one steamy choreographed scene
featuring you darling stevie i was like
it was steamy rain what was it like
doing that you know that was some sexy
choreography
not easy in a corset let me just say
that much i mean but it is savage honey
i know how to make it work and you made
it work
but is that your way of teasing the navy
like oh mama's about to return to the
stage very very soon how soon re i do
not want to torment them or tease them
guys i promise
but
it's
it's my way of just being a part of of
my show you know sometimes
maybe i won't do it every single time
but so far it's like i i like to be in
there a little bit you know it's fun
give them a little flavor a little
something something they're going to
love it now we also see ricky martin
armani we see nas in there so when it
comes to the casting are you sliding
into some dms and and putting the ask in
yourself
actually when i
when i
think of the performers
a lot of them i don't even follow
on instagram
which i'll get some bait with you right
you got to start following me this we're
bffs you've said it yourself so i like
you i like to go the professional realm
okay you know
so you know it's legit and they know
like i have a lot of respect for them as
an artist and their team and
the the rule the the protocol as it goes
but um
people get excited to be a part of this
show and a lot of times they're calling
us now and it feels so great to
have a show that has that credibility
and that people value
the stage
as much as they would even a vmas i mean
people even pull out sometimes from
other shows to be a part of it so i feel
like if we keep pushing
ourselves and challenging our show year
after year like we could really we could
do wonders you've already done wonders
and i gotta say you and asap did wonders
at the met gal you guys were a total
mood that night love to see you so happy
thank you
oh he's a cute kid to nashville i'm
gonna have to see you when you got me
i see you got the boots on you ready i'm
ready to go but honey what collaboration
do y'all have next we'd love to see the
two of you collaborate personally now
you're asking my personal best
you know i am says
i tried i tried